freshness business has nearly come to a
halt
earning a living from making traditional
clothes and handicrafts is no longer an
option
since many small businesses have gone
bankrupt
in addition to sanctions and frozen
assets the taliban's reversal of women's
participation in society has further
hindered the flow of aid to afghanistan
fresh they're struggling to keep up
morale for her seven children whose
education has suffered for years
first because of the pandemic and then
the taliban takeover
it's been one year that they have been
promising and haven't done anything
we haven't seen any results girls can't
go to schools and women can't go to
their jobs
women in cities complain of harsh
restrictions from face fails to women's
satire and suspension of many public
jobs the taliban government says it is
implementing islamic law
the ministry of vice and virtue has
replaced the ministry of women's affairs
there are some women who've been
appointed by the taliban who don't think
it's just tokenism
saying that women can't go around the
city or do their jobs freely isn't
accurate i still have female staff
working at this hospital female doctors
are doing their jobs as in the previous
government besides doctors other female
personnel are also working in some
government departments
three quarters of afghans live outside
the cities and most of rural afghanistan
is traditionally conservative that's
where the taliban's biggest support base
comes from
nilofer is a teacher and despite her
brothers being unemployed in this
government she supports the taliban she
says the majority of women in
afghanistan bear what she calls the
hijab in their own way
and that's an afghan tradition not a
taliban rule
wouldn't most women from afghanistan
look at you and hear you and think that
you've been brainwashed and this is not
what most women of afghanistan want
we aren't brainwashed i teach the quran
islam has given rights to women like
inheritance education to become a
professor and anything they want to be
if we go without the hijab it's against
the quran and if we are muslims we
should follow the quran
taliban officials have been accused of
using excessive force when women protest
they in turn want women to organize
protests after seeking permission and
they also cite safety and security as
concerns
[Music]
but to achieve that most women of
afghanistan will have to trust the
taliban and that's unlikely while most
schools for teenage girls remain closed
and promises to uphold women's rights
are not put into action
sama jawed al jazeera kabul